ich habe die letzten tage mal gefragt ob
ich dafür überhaupt noch kennen mich hat
diese banale idee gekommen einfach mal
wieder akinator hochzuladen ja leute
[Musik]
fragen oder ein wohnt eine figur in
deutschland m ja ich wohne in
deutschland glaub ich überlege ich was
zu langen natürlich wirklich in
deutschland meine figur nicht weiblich
lieber clever bottich spiele ich spiele
noch mai kräftig hoch ich würde mal
sagen ja einfach damit sie auf mich
kommen nämlich war nicht bei minecraft
freedom dabei ich spiele pfeifen warum 4
[Musik]
es war auch für das was jetzt letzten
zwar weil da war ich ja dabei in der tat
warum hier bin ich also dabei gewesen
jahr heißt da okay heißt der kanal
deiner figur kommen kräftig drücke ich
jetzt auch ja und jetzt eine figur die
buchreihe percy jackson genau da waren
wir letztes mal und drehte einfach nicht
auf mich gekommen
ja ich mag die buchwerte jackson ich
lese wirklich gerne bücher ja ich habe
nicht am 21 oktober geburtstag ja ich
kann reden ich kann auch laufen sieht
man deine figur mit riskanten die frage
ob ich den kanal konkrete habe und den
kanal hat nur der user kong crafter und
das bin ich
nein ich mag nicht hingehen ich komme
nicht ursprünglich aus salzburg ich habe
nicht im oktober geburtstag mann ich bin
auch bekannt durch zeichnungen ich habe
nichts mit dem schüleraustausch zu tun
ich lebe nicht in miami kein magisches
wesen ich gerade keine unter brille ein
paar sekunden später
warum entdeckt er die beta von chrome
strafbar aber nicht nicht
ich bin kein kind mehr ich habe mich im
sommer geburtstag meine figur gehört
kommt ja ich komme aus bielefeld kämpfen
nicht gegen das böse ich bin blond
abhängt
höher
die frage hat mir schon machen nicht bei
minecraft und hängt das ganze dilemma
botton denkbar
clever bot
aachen
luca trottel kontrast zum 4
so langsam reicht aber auch mal hier der
knapper wird der regel wirklich alles
der regen soll dritter die nicht mal im
master bilder gebaut habe wer erkennt
hier den trottel von 5 4 aber nicht mich
dabei die würde sage ich wieder auf mein
machen weiter eine figur stand auf
keinem spiel
ich habe immer noch nicht am 25 zehnten
geburtstag ich markt wurden
ich weiß zwar nicht welche youtuber also
oder weniger zur bekanntesten akinator
steht aber naja ich wurde die hübsche
bekanntlich führen nicht zu einer gruppe
ich bin kein honig habe über 20.000
abonnenten ja ich wohne im kongo aber
ich habe keine grünen haare sagt eine
gurke youtube am anfang hallo mein name
ist luca ich sagen jaja das ipad mit oh
mein gott endlich clever wollen wir
hatten warum bin ich in diesem film
lieber akinator hier mal eine ganz kurze
nachricht an dich hier hat mal seiten da
habe ich wöchentlichen part hochgeladen
wo ich irgendwas bei dir gesucht habe
und da habe ich teilweise drei oder vier
fragen braucht mich weg befinden dass
ich mich allerdings bei diesem laden
finden konnte hat es 500 fragen
gebraucht
akinator
willst du mich vor
einmal einfach auf ja und mein gott
ich wurde 800.000 mal gespielt
wollt ihr mich verarschen eigentlich
wollte ich das heutige video relativ
kurz halten weil ich noch sehr viel
lernen muss habe aber es existiert ja
auch noch ukulele das heißt wir suchen
jetzt nach uli hagmann ist eine figur
männlich ich weiß nicht ob die männliche
ist eigentlich schon aber die rede
halten mädchen also ich würde sagen ja
sie ist männlich es wäre halt kraftwerk
uli nach weniger fragen rauskommen würde
als ich war halt schon mitten heftig ich
habe wirklich nichts mit videospielen zu
tun wie hat keine musik video
hochgeladen
wie komme ich älter bin ja die hypo
markt ist die besteht auch voll
sie hat nicht in liechtenstein gelebt
sie fotografiert nicht gerne wie nicht
weltweit bekannt sich nicht wieder
kommission serie mit die kommt mit
parteilogo lilly ukulele wurde schneller
erraten als ich
bin ja auch keiner als du
fick dich
kollegen
eigentlich so böse zu mir sagen jetzt
einfach mal ja schlimme politik davor
die politik wurde auch schon vier oder
30.000 mal gespielt alter ja ja okay
stimmt so kollege hat mir gerade gesagt
hat die noch mal ein bisschen was hier
an die zuschauer also an jedem ort sagen
möchte und weil ich weiss nicht lokal
wagen eine ahnung wo 60.000 blick
verloren ich meine schafe
nein eigentlich nicht
das was ihr vom video meine damen und
herren vor ich bis jetzt ein bisschen
kurzweilig meinen vor allem jahr habe
ich nur videos hochgeladen wurden die
vier minuten gegen das ganze video
trotzdem gefallen hat es wieder mal mega
oldschool länder das wirklich machen
fetten like daher findet jetzt hier oben
ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
ihr könnt ich meinen kanal kostenlos
abonnieren umstände die auf meinen job
eingeblendet und hier unten ein anderes
video da könnte jetzt dennoch
draufklicken dass die definitiv ein
bisschen länger als dieses hier das
video hier heute so kurzweilig zu tun
mit union zur schau